alors
la politique que je mènerai dans les
cinq ans à venir sera donc écologique ou
ne sera pas
et donc
pour placer l'écologie au coeur du
nouveau paradigme politique
comme au 19ème siècle
ou face aux défis éducatifs
jules ferry
était à la fois président du conseil et
ministre de l'instruction publique
mon prochain premier ministre
sera directement chargé de la
planification écologique
[Applaudissements]
parce que cela concerne tous les
domaines tous les secteurs toutes les
dépenses tous les équipements tous les
investissements bref toutes les
politiques
ça n'est pas simplement une politique
c'est la politique des politiques
et parce que cela démontre
irréfutablement
l'importance que nous accorderons à ce
combat du siècle
le premier ministre
sera pour agir
appuyé par deux ministres forts
le ministre de la planification
énergétique
je rassure ici chacune et chacun
[Musique]
le ministre étant une fonction il peut
s'agir d'une femme ou d'un homme
comme la ministre actuelle le monde
et donc le ministre de la planification
énergétique
aura pour mission de faire de la france
la première grande nation à sortir du
gaz du pétrole et du charbon cette
possible et nous le ferons